hang on oh this is a disaster huh it's
not a disaster a table mattock you're
sure this is gonna work
No
but you want more you want more is that
what you wanted one more somebody get me
out of the tree
Tommy I need admin powers like now live
at home zombie still ahead
wait no hang on I got wait no I get
those roughed up there get the ropes off
there get the ropes off if the ropes the
best thing that's ever happened what
happened oh do attempt to pull it over
my head yeah baby laughs no no go baby
go
yes mate let it go let it go let it go
let it go go fit bone let it go oh my I
got rid of my Striders and gunship so
how about a whole bunch of these oh
Jenny wait murder relief ma calm down
host I'm not doing that dude
Oh oh my god I'm not doing it
surprisingly it's it's pretty so bad my
god how about that that good you look
good flag is so black invading this
reminds me when I was a kid and you went
in the playgrounds with the wolves Oh
Marc please still what what what take
your picture
okay hey you guys giving up hey the lady
tired yet oh my god is loads of it oh
you're getting you're tired of all this
oh my god this is horrifying is good
yeah there look I gather huh yeah Morgan
with that boom
what happened anything happen something
happen she can look at some proofs on it
me down me down no I eat FL you guys
okay you're sitting on the floor for me
you're like collection into the ground
yeah you are go up there see you coming
a good job oh okay here we go oh my god
tied to a rope swing me it's going
backwards oh I just got hit with a wagon
Oh
driving backwards party balloon here